un peuple un corps un peu savoir local
[Musique]
nous sommes à vouneuil sous biard et n'a
pu croiser monsieur capitale européenne
de la jeunesse de la culture du bon goût
et de la distinction
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ma femme mes peines il est souvent ça
et
[Musique]
sous la pluie il m
au final aux ménages j'entends encore la
foule gronde et jean on y va on y va on
y va
et cette foutue que de plus en plus fort
et de plus en plus fort plus en plus
fort
[Musique]
pamela
c'est lors d'un
[Musique]
paul hogan analyste
ce budget
tu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
/
[Musique]
oui
oh
je suis désolé
une génération qui revenait sur ses
terres car l'internet dans une sphère de
300 ans et je veux dire que je suis
connecté
mais pas qu'internet à la terre
j'espère vraiment que dans quelques
années on pourra ré équilibrer et que
par exemple ce festival qui est parfait
en rural en village
bien que rappelle chose qui se passe
partout et pas que dans l'évent nul
les faits
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
boum
c'est tout
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
tout cela
non
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]